hey youtubers is Charlie so huge news
George our Martin was at a convention
this past weekend and read from new
material from winds of winter so he
revealed some big details about
brianne's backstory that made her that
much more badass so just careful for
spoilers if you don't want to know
anything about Brienne
brian is one of those characters that's
been really put upon as she tells her
history there was that episode where she
was talking to pod explaining how they
called her Brienne the beauty as an
insult because even though you look at
her right now and she's really big
really strong total badass you have to
remember that she's probably been that
tall since she was about 15 or 16 maybe
even younger than that and it takes boys
just a little bit longer to catch up at
that age so if you think that she's
taller than say like Sir Jamie now then
imagine how big the difference was when
they were teenagers so as she tells it
as a child her father tried to marry her
off three times just like you would with
a traditional lady from a noble house
but it led to three broken engagements
just because no one would have her and
you can imagine how bad things got when
she would just embarrass people that
would get into fights with her like
she'd spar with some of the other nobles
and just kicked their asses so you can
imagine like all those young noble boys
wounded pride just saying awful awful
things about her her entire life so as
much as that sucks she's become this
amazing badass on the TV show she's
still a badass in the books the show has
just pushed her to the forefront a
little bit more she's a little bit more
of a background character in the books
but here's the really cool thing that
George R Martin did this past weekend if
you've read the Dunkin egg series sir
Duncan the tall is named the protector
of young egg Aegon v who becomes the
future king of Westeros so that series
is all about their adventures together
like this really giant hedge knight in
the future king of Westeros just Pallin
around over the Seven Kingdoms but of
the new material that George our Martin
read he named Brienne the descendant of
Sir Duncan the tall so it's just a
really easy fix to make a character that
everyone already loves that has a pretty
terrible backstory have a really amazing
back story like oh you think she had it
bad but she comes from this amazing
lineage so just think of all the amazing
things that she's gonna do hopefully she
makes it to season a she's one of those
characters that definitely throws
herself in the line of fire so given
that we have several characters now that
all have Valyrian swords including the
newest Samwell it will be such a
disappointment
if she didn't get to use Oathkeeper at
some point to just Hulk out on some
White Walkers but let me know in the
comments what do you think about Brienne
being the descendant of Sir Duncan the
tall and if you haven't read the books
he's kind of like the most famous Knight
in the history of Westeros at least at
this point the show is actually invoked
a little of Dunkin egg you may have
missed it briefly but maester aemon
talks about egg as he's dying
egg egg mother's calling you egg from
the dunk and egg series was one of
maester aemon's brothers you have to
remember mainstreaming is very very old
but it was a really touching sweet
moment especially what happened to his
family later in life at the end of his
life that King Aegon died in what was
called the tragedy at summer hall
sidenote
is actually one of the instances that
people point to when they say that
Targaryen snot all Targaryens are immune
to fire because they died in a giant
house fire like almost his entire family
was wiped out but the really cool thing
about duncan egg is that george RR
martin has actually pointed to it as his
leading choice for a spin-off should HBO
decided to do a game of Thrones spin-off
and I think they definitely want to but
Danna de Bourgh so said on finishing
what they're doing right now getting
through the next season that they
haven't announced anything about a
spin-off yet whether it's gonna have
different producers but George our
Martin is like full steam and he's like
two thumbs up definitely go for it do a
spinoff so if we get a spin-off it will
probably be the adventures of Duncan egg
George R Martin said that he's gonna
continue to write Duncan egg he'll
continue to write expanded material so
there'll be plenty more new awesome
people that he introduces but as of
right now it's just that sir Duncan the
tall is the perfect ideal of the person
that Brienne has trying to become all I
ever wanted to do was become a knight
she says that's why I've been a little
disappointed with Jaime this season so
far yeah he's been on a tear we got to
see that amazing Mad King King Slayer
flashback but I think it's especially
disappointing for book readers because
in the books he's on slightly more of a
redemptive arc in the show thus far at
least this far in the season up to
Episode six makes it seem like he's
learned not like none of Brienne's good
qualities have rubbed off on him that's
why I'm just waiting for someone to
write fan fiction where tormund and
Jaime fight for Brienne's affections or
remember Brienne will eventually head to
the Riverlands to try and secure the
help of the blackfish in Santa's quest
retake Winterfell and Jamie is being
sent to the Riverlands at the head of
the Lannister army to try and get rid of
the blackfish so they will definitely be
meeting up with each other and for those
of you that are wondering where bran is
he actually appears in the trailer
briefly here putting pod in a chokehold
like oh my god I can't believe I haven't
seen you in so long
so Bronn is still around it's just that
Jaime only just mentioned him in the
previous episode when he was like I'm
gonna get Bronn we're gonna assassinate
the high Sparrow and Cersei just pump
the brakes on it hardcore just do not do
that so I'm hoping Brienne is able to
Joffrey slap some sense into Jaime but
it kind of looks like Jamie's determined
to be a douchebag this season so you
guys let me know in the comments what do
you think is gonna happen when Jaime and
Brienne meet up and they're at odds
she's trying to get the help of the
blackfish Jaime's trying to get rid of
the blackfish but in related news my
next game of Thrones video will be the Q
& A so I'll be pulling questions for my
episode 6 video as well as this video so
just leave all your questions about
episode 6 about Duncan egg about Brienne
anything you guys want to talk about I
feel like we're mostly going to be
talking about cold hands but there's a
couple other really big things going on
wait you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my episode 6
video and you can click here to learn
about how the actor that plays Ramsay
Bolton wants to die on the show he
talked a little bit about how he wants
to go so thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight